well Ted it has been a busy one here at
Harry Reid International Airport
especially here on the ground zero level
where people have been waiting for their
bags here at baggage claim and you know
some Travelers have been pretty much
standing by just to get an update on
what's to come as far as their baggage
and kind of waiting for a little bit
it's all due to the weather as the FAA
said thunderstorms may be the cause for
arrivals to be delayed about an average
of an hour so far the people I talked to
coming in from Austin or even North
Dakota say they haven't been affected by
the weather only about 15 minutes or
less good news for them they're just
happy to touch down in Las Vegas and
they're just waiting to see where their
baggage is and they are telling me that
they're just happy to be here especially
even if it is gloomy weather coming in
from the Midwest or the East Coast even
coming down here they say it all makes
it worth it to wait those 10 to even 15
minutes now as always this is a busy
weekend like I mentioned you can already
see a lot of people waiting and standing
around as it is Martin Luther King Jr
day so because it's really busy here if
you have a flight to catch it's advised
that you should check your flight status
for any changes reporting live here at
Harry Reid International Airport Mary
Jane beliesza 8 news now advice to heed
there Mary Jane thank you for that and
ground delay for departures at Harry
Reid expected to last until seven
o'clock tonight about two more hours
today